engagé à fond dans la voie du succès la
33e foire gastronomique de dijon
remarquable synthèse de l'alimentation
française a fermé ses portes hier soir
comme vous l'avez constaté ici en la
capitale bourguignonne
le terme gastronomie ne saurait être
séparé de celui de dégustation
dégustation bien sûr de ce qui se mange
et de ce qui se boit de meilleur en
france
n'oublions pas que cet aspect attractif
d'une sorte de grand palais de la
gourmandise a largement contribué au
renom de cette manifestation économique
cette année le bilan de la foire de
dijon est extrêmement réconfortante
d'une part plus de 300000 visiteurs
d'autre part un nombre très important
d'acheteurs étrangers ils se sont
trouvés pour confronter et étudier
donnant ainsi à cette rencontre une
assise internationale d'autant plus que
parmi eux se trouvaient les
représentants de groupements d'achat
extrêmement puissant sur le plan
prestige mais aussi efficacité
deux grands congrès ont amené beaucoup
de spécialistes et techniciens de
l'alimentation et qui ont ainsi fait
connaissance avec l'économie
bourguignonne
travaillant de cette façon les
animateurs de cette 33e foire
gastronomique comptes atteint leur
double but toucher aussi bien les
spécialistes que le grand public ligne
ont enfin l'effort particulier de
décoration consentis par de nombreux
exposants et le succès obtenu par les
attractions offertes dans les
restaurants de la foire
une fois de plus l'hospitalière
bourgogne a démontré qu'elle demeurait
la terre de joie et de gaieté